- There was a chance we were
gonna see
all three of y'all on a team?
- Me, Bron and D
almost had a chance one time,
but we didn't know who was gonna
wear No. 3.
- [Announcer:] Oh!
- [Second announcer:]
Oh, Paul again
pulls off his magic.
- [Laughing]
- True or false, and why:
The Rockets should have beaten
the Warriors in the playoffs.
- You know, that was one of
the toughest things
I think I dealt with.
- [Announcer:] Ball. Got around
the screen this time.
- What if that trade was able
to happen with the Lakers?
- I knew that was coming.
It's even crazier
to think about it now,
losing Kobe and David Stern.
Man, it would've—
it've been special.
♪♪♪
Hey, what's up?
I'm Chris Paul—
point guard for
the Oklahoma City Thunder.
Wake Forest alumnus,
North Carolina boy.
Here about to answer
a few questions about myself,
the season, everything else
that's going on in life.
So, yep, I'm about to
"Take It There"
with Taylor Rooks.
- [Announcer:] Oh! Can you
make it two in a row?
He can—as he splashes home!
- [Taylor Rooks:]
OK, so first off,
thank you for spending
your off time here
on the show, bowling, Chris.
- Yeah, because my off days,
I don't like to be around him.
- [Taylor, chuckling:]
But you're stuck with him today?
- For right now.
- Is he, is he gonna do this
the whole time?
- Wait, hold on. Tell her why
you don't like being around me.
I beat him in everything we do.
Competing—it doesn't matter.
[Crowd cheering]
- [Announcer:]
Shai Gilgeous-Alexander!
- [Second announcer:]
SGA lines it up. Right down
the pipe from downtown.
[Cheering, shouting]
- Well, he's supposed to be,
like, the best bowler.
Are you the best bowler
in the NBA?
- I don't know.
I feel like I'm up there.
- All right, well, now
it's your turn to show us.
You're up first.
- Aw, man.
- Let's see what he's
talking about, Shai.
- Shai, what we gonna do?
We bowling for push-ups?
- Nah.
- [Taylor:] So what?
- [Chris Paul:]
What are we bowling for then?
Push-ups.
♪♪♪- Let's go ♪♪♪
- Here we go, C.
-Here we go.
♪♪♪- Let's go ♪♪♪
- Oh, no, she didn't.
- Oh! Boom. Boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom.
That's how you do it.
Crunch time.
I'm a clutch player.
How old are you, Shai?
- Twenty-one.
I ain't got gray hair.
- They make you feel old,
don't they, Chris?
- We don't make him
feel nothing.
He's naturally just old.
- [Chris:]
Till he steps on the court.
He be so happy on my team now
and he ain't gotta guard me.
- [Laughing] No!
- Strike club? OK—
- Listen, I promise—
- Yeah, strike club. Have you
ever got a strike?
- If he would've got a strike
right there,
this whole interview thing
was over.
I was going home.
- [Laughing]
♪♪♪
- So when we were bowling, Shai
jokingly said that you're old.
- Yep.
- Do you feel old?
- By no means. By no means.
- What is it like being
a leader in the NBA?
Cuz, it's funny, you know,
whenever I do these interviews,
I always ask different guys
about who I'm interviewing
to get stories, get questions,
and people absolutely
see you as a leader.
You're a player people
come to for advice,
when they just have questions.
Does a lot of weight
come with that?
- It's a lot of weight.
It's a lot of responsibility.
But I think
the coolest thing for me
is that, you know, obviously,
people are always
looking to me for advice
or how can I help them.
- At this point in your career,
what's more important:
money or a championship?
- I mean, obviously I want to
win a championship,
but am I gonna...
you know what I mean?
- Mmhmm.
- Like, are you here
doing this for free?
- I am not.
- No. Exactly.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- So, like, I got a family
I gotta take care of.
Now, when I compete
- Yeah.
- like, I'm competing.
I always want to win.
I'm unbelievably competitive.
But I got a lot of great stuff
that goes on in my life.
I've got two beautiful kids,
an amazing wife,
and I got a whole family.
I don't go to bed,
like, with a picture
of the trophy, like,
"Ooh, I gotta have it.
I gotta have it."
No, not on duty.
- Yeah. OK.
- Yeah.
- No, that makes sense.
There's things bigger than
just winning that championship.
- But that doesn't mean
I don't want to win it
and that I'm not going
to strive to win it.
- Mmhmm.
- But is that my, like,
ultimate goal in life?
Absolutely not.
- What is your ultimate goal
in life?
- I got a lasting imprint
that I not only want
to try to, you know,
make on others, but my kids.
- No, I feel that.
- So, yeah,
the NBA championship—
kiss all of my ass.
Like, Little Chris and Camryn
is my priority.
- That's great. OK.
So if you could be commissioner
of the NBA for one day—
- One day.
- You got one day.
You can change one
on-the-court rule.
- That's tough. Man.
Uh...shoot.
Man, I'd probably
lower the goals
at least for one quarter.
[Taylor scoffing]
Listen. Listen.
I got all types of dunks
I'd be doing.
- [Taylor:]
What are you trying to do?
- Lower the goal
for one quarter.
- [Laughing]
- Um, and—
- From what—10 to what?
Like, how low are we going?
- I mean, I might just need
like nine and a half.
The game is the game.
- Was that a "The Wire"
reference?
- Huh?
- "The game is the game."
- Have you seen "The Wire"?
- Have I seen "The Wire"?
- OK, I just needed
to make sure.
- My alias on the road
used to be Avon Barksdale.
- No way.
- [Chris:] Yeah, come on.
Don't do that.
- Should've gone, like,
maybe Marlo.
- No, no—Avon.
- Maybe a little Stringer Bell.
- Not Stringer Bell—
it was Avon Barksdale.
- OK, so as a TV guy,
if you could pick one TV world
and you're one
fictional character
in this TV world,
what are you picking?
- The character that I really,
really, like, got attached to
was Jax Teller.
Started watching
"Sons of Anarchy," and listen,
that right there goes, like,
with "The Wire."
That's one of the best shows—
- No!
- Watch it. Just watch it.
Cuz, I mean—
- I don't know if bikers
are for me.
- I didn't think it was
for me either.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- But at the end of the day,
once you start watching a show,
it's about all the stories
that's being told.
That's what gets you attached
to the show is the characters.
- Well, on every TV show,
every main character,
they have a flaw.
What's your flaw?
- That's probably a better
question for my wife.
- [Laughing]
- But, I mean,
I got a lot of them.
I'm probably not very patient,
anxious a lot of times.
I'm sure some people would
probably say I'm pushy or bossy
and all the different
type stuff,
so, I mean, I could
run down a whole list.
♪♪♪
- When I was researching
for this interview,
one thing that comes up
is these articles
that talk about you
being a bad teammate.
- Mmm.
- Which—I have never heard
a player personally say,
"Chris is a bad teammate."
I've never heard anything
like that before.
Why do you think that
narrative exists about you?
- [Chris:]
Some of the people say it that
I may have been teammates with.
We did get into it,
or we did have a falling out
or altercation,
and that's that.
- Have you ever wanted
to resolve it with them?
- I think so.
If that was the case,
I would more so, like,
want to know what the issue is.
I mean, some of them I sort of
know what the issue is,
but I think I try to control
what I can control.
You know, some of my teammates
like David West,
who I played with in New Orleans
who is, like, my guy forever.
Like, we still talk.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- You know what I mean?
And I played
with the Clippers.
I still talk to DJ
about every day.
Talk to JJ Redick all the time.
Just about all the guys
that I played with there,
you know what I mean?
Still talk to Tuck
and all these guys,
Eric Gordon
and all these guys, so.
- So this idea that you
just, like, dislike the Rockets
and don't ever want to talk
to them again is false?
- When the stuff happened
with the Rockets,
I just wasn't happy about
how it went down.
As far as—
I know it's a business.
You got to do what you got
to do, but we're adults.
We can communicate.
I just had a conversation
with him a few days before that
and he was like,
"We ain't gonna trade you
to the, uh, Oklahoma."
He asked me,
"Do you wanna go there?"
I said, "No, not at this point
in my career."
He said, "All right,
I won't trade you there
because you chose
to come to us from L.A."
That was that. But I mean,
they don't owe me nothing.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- So thankfully everything
happens for a reason.
♪♪♪
- Oh, shit.
- I didn't even see it.
What happened?
- Dang!
- [Chris:] I didn't even
seen it. What happened?
You know I quit school, right?
Because of recess.
I don't play.
[Laughing]
- [Taylor:] This is it.
I can feel it.
[Shai Gilgeous-Alexander
clearing throat]
- [Chris:] Oh, this guy—
- That's crazy.
- See?
That's what he do
in shooting games too.
- [Taylor:] But, see,
I can eliminate distraction.
- [Shai:] Oh, just like you did.
- [Taylor:] Yep. I didn't go.
- Oh, oh, no, she didn't.
- Oh!
- [Shai:] Oh,
y'all are taking this
a little too serious now.
- [Taylor:] Dang!
- Y'all lucky I didn't
warm up too.
- [Chris:] Man, shut up.
- Damn.
- No, he ain't got it.
He ain't got it.
- [Shai:] Ah!
Let's go back
to playing basketball.
This ain't it right now.
[Laughing]
- OK, if you could build
the ultimate point guard—
OK, you have to take
attributes
from different point guards
to build that great one.
- Hmm.
- Build it.
- You know, I probably want
D-Rose's explosiveness.
And then you got
the different arms.
So, like, want one hand
probably, like,
Kyrie's finishes and all that.
And then on the other hand,
Shai nice with the finishes.
Like, Steve Nash was
a really good shooter.
Russ—a great rebounder.
You know, Bron is always
good at passing
and all that different
type stuff.
But I know, like, my basketball
IQ and awareness,
like, nobody
watches more basketball
than me,
you know what I mean?
So probably like D-Will
or Baron Davis', like, build.
Shooting also might be
somebody like Gilbert Arenas.
Like, Gil—see,
that's what I'm saying.
Like, that's why I get mad
when I'm talking to Shai
and guys like that,
cuz they don't be realizing
how nice people like Gil was.
- [Taylor:] Right.
- [Chris:] I'm constantly
on YouTube with Shai
and all of them showing them,
like,
"This was Gil right here."
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
And that's why they know that
I'm always harping on defense.
Cuz the league that we in now,
guys don't guard the guy,
you know what I mean?
Like, if this guy's
the nicest one on the team
and that guy's supposed to be
the nicest one
on the team,
they don't guard each other.
- Right. That's so true.
- They don't guard each other.
And I'm constantly
telling Shai all the time
that I had to go out there
and try to guard AI.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- I had to try to go—
try to guard Gil.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- It's cuz it's all right
to get your ass busted
on a given night.
- Right.
- You know what I mean?
He might drop 35 on you
or something like that,
but you—
- You'll be better for it.
- You're learning.
- Wait, what was that moment
for you?
You were like, "Uh uh,
this is different."
- Man, I think the first time
I played against AI.
I think AI might've had 24 shot
attempts in the first half.
In the first half, just going.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Chris:] You know what I mean?
You're like, "Damn,
is he gonna pass?"
You know what I mean?
- [Laughing]
- But that, that was that.
You know, Gil might be six
inches taller than me, right?
And I had to try to learn
how to guard him.
That's where a lot
of my feistiness comes from.
That's what I'm always
on Shai about.
You know, "On this night,
you guard such and such.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- But at the same time,
guess what?
I don't think
he can guard you."
- Is LeBron James a point guard?
- Bron is unique, man. And—
He can be, but at the same time,
on tomorrow night,
he can be a power forward.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Chris:] You know what I mean?
And it's so crazy,
and I mean this
when I say this:
Everybody gets so consumed
in putting in people
in a position
and what position they are
instead of just watching
and learning.
- Mmhmm.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Like, learn how to pass,
how to rebound, how to make
the right play every night.
I don't give a damn if he a
point guard, point forward.
Whatever.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- He's just nice.
- He's just out here. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- You know, I hate
to play the "What if?" game,
but I have to.
What if that trade was able
to happen with the Lakers?
- I knew that was coming.
- Because I'm also thinking
about that all of the time.
- It's even crazier, uh,
to think about it now.
You know what I mean?
Given the situation
the past few months,
losing Kobe and David Stern.
Man, it would've been special.
You know, I'll talk
about it at some point,
but me and Kobe had actually
got on the phone
and talked about,
you know, this and that,
and me and my brother was about
to get on a flight
to fly to L.A.
Uh, man. You know...
there are times
where I'll be like,
"Man, this, this
would have been..."
But, you know,
I can't get caught up in that.
It all worked out.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor:] OK. You know what,
I'm doing this one for Twitter,
because I think I speak
for all of Twitter
when I ask you this.
- Uh oh.
- Is there any chance
we will ever see
the Banana Boat Crew team up?
- [Chris:] Uhh. Never say never,
you know what I mean?
I would love that opportunity.
It would be fun.
[Taylor laughing]
It'd be special.
The road trips.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Spending that time.
That'd be super dope.
- Say in this alternate
universe, right,
you, D-Wade, Melo, Bron,
are all on one team.
What does that look like?
What kind of ball
are we playing?
- Shh, I don't know.
I don't know.
So another story:
Me, Bron, and D
almost had
a chance one time,
but we didn't know who was
gonna wear No. 3.
- But what's the next question?
- No. Whoa. OK—
what team, what conference?
I mean, give me something.
- I don't know.
-That is a—
- In this universe.
- In this universe,
there was a chance
y'all all three were gonna be
on the same team.
OK, just tell me this.
How long ago?
- Sometime...in the, in the,
in the past 15 years.
- Whatever.
[Both laughing]
- It's very important
to say Gabrielle Union
is actually the one
who was on the Banana Boat.
- Melo was not.
- Correct.
- But Melo was on the vacation.
- Yes, Melo was late.
- Yes.
- He was late.
- So Melo was late.
But these are all the members
of the Banana Boat,
including you and also Melo.
- This Banana Boat thing.
- I'm gonna ask you
some questions.
You gotta put up
who it applies to, OK?
- This is sick.
[Taylor laughing]
- All right. Out of
the Banana Boat Crew,
who is the worst texter?
- The worst texter: Melo.
Very slow on reply.
- [Taylor:] OK.
- [Chris:] Very.
We have to stay on Melo
to make sure he ain't
changed numbers.
[Both laughing]
- Who gives the best advice?
- Depends on what
you're talking about.
- OK, so for you,
if you were wanting to talk
basketball, pick someone's
brain, some basketball
quote-unquote "advice,"
who would you go to?
- Probably, probably Bron.
Probably Bron.
- [Taylor:] OK.
Yeah.
- [Taylor:] What about
life advice?
- Like, life advice—
sometimes D-Wade
has a little bit
of a different perspective
cuz he's the oldest one
out of all of us.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
He had kids first,
you know what I mean?
So I remember
when I had Little Chris
and I was asking him, you know,
about this or about that.
- Best person to be stranded
on a deserted island with?
- Stranded on a deserted island
with—
It's probably Bron.
It's probably Bron,
and that's because he...
like, he is, like,
very, like, routined
and, like, he ain't never been
on my team or nothing like that,
but you can imagine
his locker, like,
everything is, like,
where it's supposed to be.
Everything. He's very like—
- He's meticulous.
- Very, very meticulous.
And he's the guy that, like,
as soon as you get to
any location,
I don't care where it is, he
wants to know what the Wi-Fi is.
[Taylor laughing]
He's not using, like,
Bron not using his phone—
- No data.
- No, he's not using his phone
unless he's connected
to the Wi-Fi.
- Who is the worst person
to be stranded
on a deserted island with?
- Hmm. It might be Melo.
[Taylor laughing]
You wanna know why?
- Why?
- You know why? And this is why.
Because if you're
on a deserted island,
you would actually
at least wanna be able
to talk to the other person
that you're with.
You know what I'm saying?
[Taylor laughing]
You wanna be trying to
figure out
how are we gonna
get off this island?
- Yeah.
- And Melo is gonna be
nowhere to be found.
[Taylor Laughing]
That's my dog.
Melo is gonna be
nowhere to be found.
- Melo's not there
with you. OK.
Who has the worst playlist?
- The worst playlist?
Probably D-Wade.
- [Taylor:] Why him?
- [Chris:] Cuz if you got
a playlist playing,
he probably gonna play
a song that he done made,
he done created.
There's not a thing that
D-Wade has not done.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- So I'm sure he's got, like,
a few tracks out there
or something like that.
- Mmhmm. Probably. Probably.
- Yeah, you could be
listening—
- He's probably singing
on it though—not rapping.
- You could be listening
to Roddy Ricch.
You could be listening
to Drake, Jay.
And then next thing you know,
D gonna put himself
in there on the thing.
- Most likely to get
to the free-throw line?
- Most likely to get to
the free-throw line?
This one. This one.
Cuz he be out there
playing football.
- Absolutely.
- He playing football
playing basketball—
come through, running people
over and stuff like that.
Like, man, what is this?
- All right, last one.
Most likely
to hit the game-winner?
- I mean, we all can sort of do
that, but Melo does that, too.
- Yeah.
Melo, Melo.
And I actually seen, like,
a clip
of that recently
or something like that that say
like he got the most
game winners—
so I'm kind of cheat—
he got the most game-winners
out of anybody,
I think, since he came
into the league.
- OK. Let me see these.
My question:
What team did these three
almost end up on?
- Them three?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- An All-Star team.
- [Taylor:] An All-Star team.
But clarify: There was
a maybe NBA league team
you all three were almost on.
- We all almost played on an
All-Star team together, I think.
- [Taylor:]
I'm done with you. I'm done.
[Laughing]
♪♪♪
- Ah, that's a strike.
Dang!
Ugh! OK.
- You know, you shoot it
and then you just walk away
and you hear,
"Ch-chh!"
- [Shai:] That's what it was?
Oh, OK.
- Looks like you gonna be
getting 10 push-ups
on call sometime.
- [Shai:] Choke, choke.
Ooh, I'm in trouble.
It's over with.
Ooh, it's over.
- Get your strike.
Game ain't over till it's over.
- [Taylor:]
Come on, Shai. This is it.
♪♪♪
OK. Hold on a minute.
Chris is the winner.
I'm in second place.
- No, you're the first loser.
- Which would mean—
- [Laughing]
- Which would mean Shai
is dead last, and I think
I'm on call for a push-up,
and I'm gonna give it to you.
- You gonna count them out
for me?
- [Taylor:] Yeah, I got you.
- [Shai:] Ugh!
- [Taylor:] One, two...
- [Shai:] Hey.
Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
We're not doing that, Chris.
We're not doing that.
Come on now.
- Three.
- Yo, yo, yo, Taylor,
we're not doing that.
[Laughing]
- Oh, five, six.
- [Taylor:] Seven!
- Seven, seven, seven, seven.
- [Taylor:] Eight.
- [Chris:] Oh, oh,
what's happening?
- [Taylor:] You got two more.
- You missed a couple
when you turned around.
- [Taylor:] No, I did not.
No, I did not.
You got two more.
We run a tight ship.
Nine, 10. There we go.
- Boy real strong in here.
- Good game.
That—Wow!
Really, Shai? You're not—
Down low? Down low?
- We're gonna run that back
once you get nice, though,
ain't we?
- I'm sick of both
of y'all—cheating.
[Laughing]
- All right, let me walk
you out, Chris.
- All right.
- I'm practicing. So y'all—
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
True or false, and why?
You miss eating bacon.
Tru... nah.
False. False.
- OK.
- I think I'm more so miss
eating chicken.
- OK.
- Like, chicken wings.
- Mmhmm.
- Dang.
That's a hell of a question.
- True or false and why?
Top black athletes
should start going to HBCUs.
- True. True.
And I'm a firm believer in that.
Like, it has to start somewhere.
And I know somebody will be
quick to say,
"Well, you didn't."
I think that if kids
do go to these HBCUs,
that we've seen that
the networks or whatever,
they're gonna come
wherever the kids are.
- True or false and why?
The Rockets should have beaten
the Warriors in the playoffs
last season.
- Should've?
Shoot, hell, which season?
Maybe this last year
and the year before.
I wish we would have.
- Mmhmm.
- You know what I mean?
But we didn't.
And so you gotta move on.
You know, that was
one of the toughest things
I think I dealt with was,
you know,
how close, you know,
and then it didn't happen.
So gotta get back to work.
- Absolutely. OK.
Well—
I have successfully spent
the entire off-day with you.
- Yeah, and that's a sick game
right there.
[Laughing]
I'mma use that,
just for the record.
- Because it's, like,
you gotta pick one.
- Gotta make a decision.
- And the "why?" part.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- Like, that ain't like
just true or false.
You asking why.
Like, that's—that ain't it.
- But you liked the game cuz
you're gonna take it home.
- It's all right. It's all
right. It's all right.
- Well, thank you for spending
so much time with us.
- We went bowling. I beat Shai.
- Yes.
- You beat me, but next time
it's not gonna be that way.
- Don't do that.
- All right.
Thank you so much, Chris.
- Thank you so much, Taylor.
I really appreciate it.
- So good to see you.
- You too, definitely.
Bye, y'all.
- [Chris, exhaling:] All right.
♪♪♪